l'effervescence d'une élection à chaque
coin de rue ou presque
des affiches de candidats aux
législatives l'espoir d'une
normalisation pour ce pays en pleine
reconstruction
frappé de plein fouet par des sanctions
occidentales et une crise économique
d'ampleur depuis 2011 et le début d'un
conflit qui a coûté la vie à des
milliers de personnes c'est la troisième
fois que les syriens sont appelés aux
urnes pour des législatives qui coïncide
cette année avec les vingt ans au
pouvoir du président bachar al assad
la configuration 2100 candidats en lice
pour 250 sièges de députés ont repoussé
à deux reprises en raison du commis 19
ces élections revêtent des enjeux claire
reconstruire le pays et contrôler
l'inflation
les revendications des gens qui ont de
demandes simples pour vivre leur
préoccupation est de savoir comment
obtenir de la nourriture et autres
nécessités du quotidien
grand favori du scrutin le parti bass
lié à bachar al assad est au pouvoir
depuis un demi siècle
comme un symbole certains syriens se
rendront dans d'anciens bastions des
insurgés pour voter en tout sept mille
trois cent treize bureaux de vote seront
mises à disposition des électeurs sur le
plan économique la syrie confronté à la
pire crise de son histoire aggravée par
une forte dépréciation de sa monnaie et
des mesures punitives imposées par les
états unis des sanctions que damas
déplore l'amour si les états unis rêve
que la syrie et son peuple se soumettent
à leur condition alors je dis qu'ils
peuvent continuer à rêver car cela
n'arrivera jamais
le président restera aussi longtemps que
le peuple syrien le voudra et pour être
plus précis l'objectif de ces sanctions
et d'influencer l'élection
présidentielle qui approche et quiconque
dira le contraire se trompent
une élection présidentielle qui aura
lieu dans un an avec les mêmes enjeux
que ces législatives répondre à une
crise protéiforme sans précédent pour
permettre aux syriens de retrouver une
vie normale
pour rappel 80% de la population
syrienne vit au dessous du seuil de
pauvreté selon le programme alimentaire
mondial de l'onu et le communisme 9 à
aggraver un peu plus la situation du
pays le pib estimée en 2019 à seulement
un tiers de ce qu'ils étaient avant la
guerre sera encore plus bas en 2000